but there are still questions chris
about this virtual draft we talked about
it yesterday and another thing that
emerged on wednesday from espn
the concern that you've got all of these
it workers who are scurrying around to
get the homes ready of coaches general
managers owners etc so that the draft
can go off without a hitch well
there are people who are in their homes
who don't necessarily want the it guy or
the i.t gal showing up in their homes
and maybe
entering with the coronavirus and the
i.t workers don't necessarily want to go
into a home that may be rife with the
coronavirus because of that very real
dynamic with this virus that people can
be walking around with it with no
symptoms at all so that's a concern that
means they got to find a way to figure
this out in a manner that properly
addresses those concerns because those
are legitimate concerns by the human
beings who are involved in this process
yeah you're i mean you're right big time
concerns you know mike i got two friends
in the coaching world that i've been
like face timing with and stuff
and i can tell you that them and their
family and their wives and you know the
wife is the real head coach of most nfl
coaches families because she's the one
that's got to be there and you know run
the house why the the coach is coaching
the football team
they're taking this kobet 19 pandemic
serious serious lockdown like they put
me on the grill at times like hey chris
are you being good or how serious you
guys being with a lockdown they want to
check in on us so i get it like yeah i i
don't know if i would feel comfortable
about a guy that i know yes hey nbc
technician they talked about it coming
here at first to hook up something to to
make better for the show i wasn't
thrilled about that when they first said
that i was like what i don't know if i
want anybody in my house so they got to
figure that out that is a very real
component and i would be concerned if
i'm an i.t guy or a coach's family it's
a tough one
yeah see on one hand the nfl doesn't
want technological issues to be an
excuse for teams failing to get their
picks in on time and on the other hand
the nfl is moving heaven and earth or at
least trying to before the draft to
ensure that there won't be any technical
problems and there is a balance there
and they're going to be certain things
that they just aren't going to be able
to do because
you ultimately have to look the stay at
home orders that are preventing people
from going to the team's facilities in
most of the states where the nfl does
business those same stay-at-home orders
if you read them and apply them the way
that they're written they prevent an i.t
person from leaving their own house
and coming to your house it's one thing
to go to a team's facility to do
necessary work there but entering
someone's house and having someone in
your house the these are part of the
reasons why these stay-at-home orders
are in place
yeah no you're right and you know mike
the other thing too
you know this is they're getting a trial
run in this stuff right now as we speak
you know all these coaches and teams are
having zoom group staff meetings where
they're talking about the draft and
they're going through it and the coach
is sitting at home you know with with
with his video board and he's watching
film with coaches while they're on zoom
paying attention so they've got a little
head start here as far as you know how
to run this and i think at the very
least or at the very base level if we
can't decide on the i.t guys going to
anybody's house
that should work and then when it comes
time to the pick
mike i mean
is it against the law can we just dial a
number on a hard line and say hey roger
hello ring ring ring and then we don't
have to worry about too much technology
on that standpoint or from that
standpoint so you know i think there's a
lot in place as is right now
one of the points that was made recently
on nfl network and this is
a dynamic that is in place for every
draft an open conference call with all
teams and the league office that never
hangs up that is your ultimate fail-safe
if the technology doesn't work you get
on the line and say the new england
patriots take so and so with the pick
that's currently on the clock so they
have plenty of
of redundancies built into the system
they have plenty of fallbacks in place
but there are some practical impediments
to getting everything to where it needs
to be and one of those is this concern
about the i.t workers being in people's
homes
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports